Shakespeare's Globe puts misogyny and
racism warning on a midsummer night yes
he wasn't supposed to know that the
Norms of society are going to change 500
years he's a [__] genius mate what do
you mean he should have known he should
have been able to look into the future
exactly and predict what's happening are
you a genius or what yeah are you
talented are you the creator of some of
the greatest works in the history of
humanity Shakespeare if you'd spent less
time sitting on your ass writing things
like should I compare Victor with
someone's day they aren't more lovely
and more temperate if you'd actually
spent more of the time training your
brain to see into the future yeah maybe
this kind of nonsense wouldn't have
happened and anyway did you not have
unconscious bias training in your day
mate yeah if you didn't why not when you
seek it out and if it wasn't available
why didn't you start it right it would
don't have unconscious bars shining up
there at the moment